ماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا من
خلال النظر إلى ذلك من حيث الأيام السبعة
التي استغرقها ذلك حتى
يحدث حقيقة أنهم على ما يبدو يريدون المضي قدمًا
في آه على كييف وتطويقه
أعتقد أن أول شيء هو أنه من
الواضح تمامًا أن بوتين  يدفع من أجل
ممر بري إلى شبه جزيرة القرم ، أعني أن
هذا هدف واضح أه أنت تعلم أنه
كان لديه شبه جزيرة القرم تحت سيطرته في
الاتحاد الروسي منذ عام 2014 ولم
يكن قادرًا على إمدادها إلا عبر
جسر المضيق الملعون وهكذا  بالطبع ،
إنه يتطلع إلى إنشاء ذلك
الممر البري أسفل
الساحل السفلي لبحر آزوف
أم ، وأعتقد أن الشيء الثاني هو
طريقة التصلب والمشاكل التي يواجهها
في تأمين تلك
المدن الشمالية الرئيسية في كييف بشكل واضح و  خاركوف
أيضًا وهذا يعود إلى
الدفاعات الأوكرانية كما قلت سابقًا ،
لكن علينا أيضًا أن نشعر بالارتياح من
حقيقة أنه بمجرد أن يعلق بين
الروس يعلقون في
المدن سوف يبطئون القتال في المدينة  إنها
صعبة حقًا على المهاجم ، فهي
تبتلع كميات هائلة من دفاعات القوى العاملة
لها ميزة محددة جدًا
حقًا ، لذا إذا كان هناك حصار
إذا حاولوا محاصرة
كييف على سبيل
المثال المزايا مع حسنًا ، فأنت تعرف
ما أقوله هو  أنه
إذا بدأ الروس في اختراق
المدينة ، فإن قتال
الشوارع يكون قتالًا صعبًا حقًا ، فهو
كثيف العمالة ، والخسائر
فادحة جدًا
بالطبع القلق الآخر
ونرى أنه بالفعل استخدام
عشوائي أه نيران غير مباشرة بشكل جيد
كنت أذهب  أن أسألك عن ذلك لأن
الكثيرين قد اقترحوا أن هذه الأيام السبعة
من عدم القدرة على فعل ما
اعتقدوا أنهم سيفعلونه
في غضون يومين في الواقع ، ذكرت وكالة أنباء روسية
يوم السبت أن
يومين في أوكرانيا قد عادت إلى
روسيا واضطروا إلى إزالتها على
الفور ، نعم ، وما هذا
يدل على أن بوتين يتعرض
للإذلال هنا لم يسلمه جيشه ،
لذلك سيكون أو  عندما
يأمر جاراسيموف رئيس الأركان العامة بالتصدع للوقوع في مكانه
واستخدام كل الوسائل التي
يحتاجها تحت تصرفه
ضد المدنيين ، فإن ذلك سيعني
المدفعية العشوائية بعيدًا في المدن ،
وأخشى أن نشهد زيادة في
الخسائر في صفوف المدنيين تزيد من
الكارثة الإنسانية أم  وأخيرًا ، ومن
المحتمل أيضًا تسوية
المدن ، وأخشى أن أقول إنني
لا أعتقد أننا رأينا أي شيء حتى الآن فيما
يتعلق بالدمار
المحتمل حدوثه إذا كنت تريد أن ترى ما
يفعله الروس عندما يفعلون  إنهم
يدمرون مدينة ، انظر إلى ما حدث لحلب ،
انظر إلى ما حدث لجروجيان ، أنا
أكره حقًا الحديث عن هذا
ولكن بوتين فعل ذلك ، وقد رفع
المخاطر وكان لديه في الخطاب الأول
هدده دون أن يقول
عواقب مثلك '  لم أر في تاريخك أبدًا
إذا حاولت التدخل
معنا ، فقد أخذ معظم الناس ذلك لي في
نوع من الاستجابة النووية ،
ثم تابع يوم الأحد من خلال وضع
النواة الخاصة به  يُزعم أن قوات الأذن في حالة تأهب قصوى
وتحدثت إلى وزير الدفاع الأمريكي
السابق الليلة الماضية أم ويليام كوهين
الذي قال إنك تعلم أنه قد يعتقد أنه
يمكنه استخدامه ، ولا أعرف سلاحًا نوويًا تكتيكيًا صغيرًا
ماذا يعني ذلك على الأرض
ما هو صغير
تكتيكي وما يفعله هو أنه من الممكن حتى
أن يؤدي ذلك إلى
تدمير كامل لروسيا
لأنه في نهاية المطاف يتم الدفاع عن الناتو
بالرادع النهائي الرادع النووي ،
لذا فإن أي تلميح لاستخدام الأسلحة النووية من
قبل بوتين سيؤدي إلى
انتقام لا يوصف
من شعبه.
أسألك عما تعتقد أنه
لا يمكنك الدخول في رأس أي شخص
ولا يمكنك الدخول في سلسلة القيادة العسكرية
في روسيا ، لكن
ما يحدث أعني هو أن
الجيش لم يعرف ما
الذي سيرى عليه  على الأرض ، لا
يخبرون بوتين ، هل تعتقد أن جاراسيموف وشويغو قادة عسكريون متطورون ، هل سيطلقون أو
سيطلقون
النار على ما يجري
على الأرض ، أتمنى أن أعرف كما قلت
إي  rlier iii أعتقد أن هذا
فشل في سيطرة القائد الروسي
وأن الروس يبرهنون على
أنهم ليسوا جيشًا جيدًا كما أنهم
أقوياء جدًا ، دعنا نوضح أنهم
يمتلكون معدات جيدة
جدًا وأنت تعلم أنهم استمروا في ذلك  المطاردة
ولكنهم يظهرون بعد ذلك
عدم القدرة على تحريك القوات الكبيرة
، وهو عمل معقد
يتطلب علمًا للحرب يتطلب
تدريبًا معقدًا
وفي الواقع ما
يثبتونه هو عقلية سوفيتية هنا
أه لا أفعل  أعتقد أن الأمر متروك
لنوع الطلبات ، ولكن لا ينبغي أن نشعر
بالراحة من ذلك
لأنهم سيتعلمون وسيتعلمون بسرعة كبيرة ،
والعامل الآخر هو الروح المعنوية وهو أمر مهم حقًا